وضع وضع صعب انه انا هون اولادي ما بشي
هذا
الا اللي مات اول باول لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله ولكن لما اسال عن الكبير انه اولادك
طيبين العالم مو كلهم
هذا اللي راح وينك اللي جوا معيد
لا يوصف صراحه لا يوصف يعني القهر اللي
صرنا فيه لا يوصف والله كسر الاكبر انه
اخذ لاختي
ابنه ينقذني
يعني فوق الكسر صرت بكسر تاني وين انا انا
جاي اختي تساعدني اولادها واجي اخذ لابنه
بعدها
والله
قبالك انه
انه لحق انزله
او يلا اسمع اصوات الناس
وقت اللي وقت البنايه على العالم ما ما
سمعت صوت بني ادم
كله سكت
فماري شاب ابن اختي تحت البنايه عم بقول
لك بسرعه بعد ما بقت البنايه عم بقول لك
بسرعه بسرعه انزلوا وقت البنايات
فقلت له
يا احمد يا احمد يا احمد معه ابنه هو كمان
قلت له
المشهد كان كارثه
الناس
تصرخ بتعطى لابني انت طالع لي اخواتي
فكان يعني المشهد كارثي كارثه
من ابرز القصص او احد القصص اللي هي لحد
الان في بالي
صوت معاذ وانا عم طلعه للصحه الامداني
يمسك فيديو لا تتركني طلعني
لحد الان يعني صوته مسكت ايده لايدي ما عم
تفارقني بنوب
وبهاي اللحظات نحن عم نطلع معاذ وغيره وعم
طالع احياء واموات
وايضا كمان يعني كان تفكيرنا عند عائلاتنا
اهلي هن بخير في حدا عم يطلعوهم او هن
بنايتهم
وفي حدا معهم